Kevin ate one slice of pizza and Emily
ate two slices if Kevin ate one-fifth of
the pizza one-fifth of the pizza what
fraction of the pizza is remaining so
let's just think about how many total
pieces because in order to figure out
the fraction of the piece of the
fraction of the pizza that is remaining
we need to figure out the number of
pieces remaining number of remaining
pieces divided by the total number of P
of pieces total number so let me write
this way total number of slices over the
total number so number of slices
remaining over total number of slices so
let's figure out the total number of
slices that they were there originally
they tell us Kevin eat one slice of
pizza and that is 1/5 of the pizza one
slice is 1/5 of the pizza that tells us
these two pieces of information tell us
if one slice is 1/5 of the pizza that
tells us that the pizza originally had
five total five total slices so this
number right over here is five and now
what is what are the number of pieces or
number of slices remaining so we started
off with five total slices Kevin ate one
so let's subtract out the one that Kevin
ate Emily ate two so let's subtract out
those two and we're left with five minus
one minus two we're left with two slices
remaining two remaining two remaining
slices so this right over here is going
to be two so there's two fifths of the
pizza is remaining